éclair tas devant un épidémiologiste
chef du service des maladies
infectieuses du chu de rennes bonsoir
pierre dhénin merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france le nouveau des
nouveaux cas qui augmente d
hospitalisation aussi clairement est-ce
qu'on doit s'inquiéter aujourd'hui
je c'est vrai que ça augmente parce
qu'on était tombé vraiment très bas mais
ce qui peut rassurer c'est qu'on est
quand même à dix fois moins que ce qu'on
a vu au sommet des vagues précédentes en
terme d'incidence donc on est passé de
44 à 48 54 pour cent mille d'incidence
donc ça ou manque il faut renforcer les
efforts il faut certainement continuer à
essayer de donner lé troisième dose à
ceux pour qui c'est indiqué donc il ya
du travail à faire mais la situation ne
ressentent pas un début d'une quatrième
vague et quand même ça ressemble plus à
une petite bosse qui justifie que l'on
fasse mieux
mais en tout cas 55 départements dépasse
tout de même le seuil dallaire en trente
deux départements la semaine dernière
vous comment vous expliquer cette
recrudescence
on arrive à un moment où les gens qui
ont été vaccinées il ya plus de six mois
sont moins bien protégés notamment chez
les personnes âgées parce qu'ils ont des
défenses immunitaires qui sont moins
qu'ils tiennent moins longtemps dans le
temps donc il faut faire cette troisième
dose il faut la faire en commençant par
ceux qui ont des systèmes immunitaires
les plus fragiles et je pense que ça
explique en partie pourquoi ça remonte
un petit peu donc il faut qu'on
s'applique là dessus alors la
vaccination justement en plus de 76% la
population totale
antico vie n'est pas administré aux
moins de 12 ans ne suffit pas pour
l'immunité en tout cas pas suffisamment
dans le temps
ça a suffi pour nous permettre en france
métropolitaine d'avoir quasiment pas de
vagues au moment de l'automne alors que
et de l'été alors que dans des
départements d'outre-mer qui était pas
bien vacciné sec est catastrophique donc
faut pas voir les choses de manière trop
négative on a on a sauvé beaucoup de
monde et on a évité mais probablement
une nouvelle
situation catastrophique cet été au
début de l'automne c'est pas si mal 75 %
de gens ayant reçu deux doses il faut
juste continuer le chemin et le bon
n'est pas assez haut mais il est bon en
revanche
père hâtif d'accélérer d'accélérer le
pas sur on le disait les personnes âgées
ça pose encore problème il n'y a pas
cette troisième phase au nécessaire
oui c'est sûr que c'est là qu'il faut
qu'on fasse le plus d'efforts parce que
là la fois ils sont parfois difficiles à
atteindre d'où les efforts pour aller
même les vacciner à domicile et qu'en
plus c'est eux qui perdent la protection
le plus vite parce que les anticorps les
globules blancs fonctionne moins bien 80
ans que quand on en a 20 pour les autres
ça tient encore les personnes qui ont
déjà été
vaccinées
donc pas les personnes âgées tout le
reste de la population y compris
d'ailleurs les plus de 12 ans pour le
moment pas de troisième dose nécessaire
en vue
ça va sûrement est nécessaire mais ce
sera nécessaire - moins vite que pour
les autres la plupart des gens entre 20
et 50 ans qui ont été vaccinés comme ils
étaient a priori charisme était plutôt
vacciner en trombe mars et juillet ceux
là sont encore bien protégé pour les
mois qui viennent c'est pour ça qu'ils
sont pas dans les priorités actuellement
sauf maladie qui les rend plus fragiles
aujourd'hui on le voit
peut-être une baisse des gestes
barrières on se fait davantage la bise
on fait plus trop attention à ce que ça
inquiète le médecin que vous êtes ont
finalement ma foi le vaccin suffit
il suffit visiblement pas puisqu'on voit
quand même de temps en temps des
vaccinés qui attrapent la maladie c'est
pas une protection de 100% mais je ne
suis je trouve pas qu'on se relance
relâche tant que ça sur les mesures
barrières quand on se promène dans la
rue on voit que les gens continuaient à
mettre le masque notamment en intérieur
dit je pense on est des humains quoi on
ne peut pas fonctionner comme des
machines tout le temps et je trouve que
globalement les français sont comme
beaucoup d'efforts depuis un an et demi
vous travaillez en ch ur on a parlé ces
derniers temps des vins pension de lits
fermés dans dans les hôpitaux vous le
voulez le constater aujourd'hui comment
vous vous l'expliqué pierre tattevin
on a eu des lits fermés au cours des
dernières années ça a été un mouvement
qui elle n'a pas aidé même pour la prise
en charge d autres maladies mais plus
récemment nous on est restés à notre
niveau de lit habituel je crois que
c'est surtout en ile de france où ils
ont été obligés de fermer des lits par
manque de personnel et où la situation
est plus compliquée merci en tout cas
du service des maladies infectieuses du
chu de rennes d'avoir été avec nous de
nous avoir un petit peu rassurés même
merci à vous
merci d'arrêter en direct sur rt
français